all right lunch money time miss polina
how are you i'm good somebody or zach
asked how your first father's day went
it was very fatherly sophia got a very
fatherly actually uh sophia and polina
collaborated and got me a a very nice uh
very nice gift i was uh uh very very he
cried
i'm kidding he almost cried
he thought about crying polino wishes
that's her goal is when she gives me a
gift she's always like i hope i can make
it i i can't believe you
yeah
life has hardened you okay uh
bitcoin
bitcoin bitcoin hearthstone to me
[Laughter]
you you've seen you see what's going on
all right go ahead so bitcoin's been
jumping around like it's playing jump
rope i honestly don't know this article
is like five minutes old it's probably
old by now i
i don't know bitcoin rebound seven
percent
so one of the things that people have to
realize is that there is a huge
discrepancy between the old system and
the new system the
old legacy financial system operates
very centralized and also has hours of
operations and so it's close on the
weekends news flash this weekend
specifically is a three
day weekend for the banks meaning that
saturday sunday and today there is no
ability to move funds in the regular
banking system uh in size especially
between your bank account and let's say
uh a crypto exchange uh the new system
operates 24 7 365 and therefore there
are no hours of operations you can move
things freely et cetera and so when you
start to overlay those two things what
happens is during a three-day weekend uh
like this for 72 hours people cannot
take their fiat currencies and get them
into the crypto exchanges for the most
part and because they can't do that it
cuts off a large portion of uh kind of
new capital that would come into the
market to buy lower prices right if
prices go down some portion of people
want to go buy it at a lower price
whether that's a good idea or not that's
why they're taking risk in the market
but if their banks aren't open they
can't get the money into the account so
what ends up occurring is that there's
less buying liquidity there which means
the prices start to fall as prices start
to fall then you get liquidations it's
kind of this cascading effect if there's
big liquidations that pushes the price
lower which then triggers more
liquidations and it continues and
continues and continues and so naturally
what we saw over the weekend was exactly
that was bitcoin started to fall it was
hitting these liquidation points uh at
some point it stopped
around 17 000-ish you know kind of
mid-17 thousands and it's not back over
twenty thousand and so it's very
interesting to watch uh just the
sentiment on twitter to watch how
bearish people are uh if you go back to
the 2018 uh bear market people were
literally questioning like is this going
to be over right that was literally the
thing i mean there's a tweet of mine uh
back from 2018 november of 2018 that
people uh i guess when founders started
retweeting again which was norelle
robini was literally like it's over and
so i responded i was like if you think
it's over like let's make a bet
right and i basically was saying hey
it's gonna go back to his all-time high
uh but like that was not a crazy
question to ask in 2018. now i don't
think very many people think that uh
it's over that it's going to zero and so
i think that you know look there's
always risk in markets you don't want to
catch falling knives you you've got to
have a plan all this type of stuff that
ends up being just timeless investing
principles but understanding the
difference between the new system and
the old system and why hours of
operations uh is a mismatch is a huge
piece of understanding why bitcoin went
down so much uh over the weekend
what do you think
oh god i think that
planet planet is uh not as uh uh cool as
a cucumber like me uh when the price
falls now the rules of reverse i used to
be cool as a cucumber yeah
it's gonna go back up like just just buy
more now planet is like this is like
kind of crazy it's no it's just i think
the volatility is making me queasy
queasy yeah that's about the q yes yeah
q-u-e-a-s-y wow
spelling bee champ
who would ever write that word
all right listen next janet yellen
what's going on with her uh so a lot of
americans fear a recession is coming and
she says it's not at all imminent she
said that she expects the economy to
slow
it's been growing at a very rapid rate
as the economy as the labor market has
recovered and we have reached full
employment it's natural now that we
expect a transition to steady and stable
growth but i don't think a recession is
at all inevitable does yellen live on
earth
well hold on let me actually uh let me
give you the bowl case for her argument
which is or maybe not full case but like
let me defend her argument for a second
which is uh inflation's too high it duh
right so like okay we agree finally uh
even though maybe we disagreed before
but okay agreed the second thing is
an inflation or a recession doesn't have
to happen have to
but where i disagree
is i don't know if it's not imminent we
only need two quarters of economic
contraction we already got one so we're
like 50 percent of the way there q1 was
a gdp contraction
so
if we just get it in q2 then like we're
gonna reset you know what i mean like
it's not that crazy if she was saying
this before we had a single quarter of
gdp negative growth then you'd be like
oh okay like we need at least two
quarters of this we already got one so
that's the part where it seems like a
little weird uh to say now what i will
argue is why is she saying this i
personally believe it's because it's all
a confidence game and if people think
that a recession is coming what do they
naturally do they start to not spend
money oh i think a recession is coming
oh let me start saving more let me not
spend on something frivolous like that
word frivolous do you know what i'm
spelling
uh well i'm not doing spelling in public
uh math and spelling not my thing uh and
then all of a sudden if you say hey i'm
not gonna go spend stuff
spend money on frivolous things but also
i may start to buy
uh
lower cost items i may actually say you
know what i'm not gonna go to the movies
this weekend i'm gonna save the money
and i'll just watch something at home
and so when you start to kind of stack
all this up
if people think a recession is coming
you could actually accelerate it because
they would change their consumer
behavior yeah it's the same thing like
with inflation if i think inflation's
coming well guess what i do if i'm a
small business i start to raise my price
it's just it's just hard to instill
confidence in the people like just
through an interview on whatever she
went on this week abc's this week when
you go to the grocery store and you see
prices going up you you know you you see
it in everyday life it's hard to believe
what somebody's saying on tv i think the
inflation for sure they can't argue
anymore like that's that that argument
came and left the originally they were
trying to say that it was transient
right or transitory
uh yeah of course that's what they're
arguing now they can't argue that
anymore uh the recession again is the
thing that they uh are debating now um i
think it will be very difficult for them
to avoid a recession uh given what they
are currently doing but yeah i guess you
can't really see a recession at the
store but like i think it's like in the
air
yeah look there's we're already starting
to see some layoffs occur uh we have hit
you know relatively low unemployment 3.5
or so uh but my expectation is that that
will continue to uh tick up we've seen
stocks go down we've seen crypto go down
we've seen bonds go down we've seen
commodity prices drop real estate is
definitely coming uh you see the uh
residential mortgage rates explode
upwards the cost of capital is getting
more expensive they're conducting
quantitative tightening like it's just
all the machinery is moving towards a
contraction and when you get a
contraction eventually you get negative
growth yeah what's going on with meta
okay so meta formerly known as facebook
is launching an online store where
facebook instagram and messenger users
can purchase digital clothing for their
avatar in prada the first brands on the
store are prada balenciaga and tom brown
is that how you say
enclose include a motocross outfit a
logo hoodie and suits ha right up your
alley
no no you don't what do you think about
this idea so i think it's actually
interesting because
luxury fashion in the digital world
because uh i went to a conference long
time ago and there was this like 15 year
old there and she was explaining to us
how like people were buying
skins for their like
guns and like artwork for their digital
houses like everything was digital and
she was like this is what we value and i
was like oh my god that's crazy but now
i can see how people would buy this
i don't think like roblox is huge
yeah i understand that but i don't think
you're going to get mainstream people to
replace their physical consumption with
digital consumption but i do think that
you can uh expand your revenue streams
so rather than cannibalize like if
you're one of these luxury providers you
could say okay hey we get a hundred
dollars of revenue in the physical world
i don't think that people are gonna say
oh i'm not gonna spend the money in the
physical world now i'm going to shift it
to this digital avatar thing and so
naturally what we're going to do is
we're going to still have 100 revenue
but it's like 70 physical 30 digital i
think this is actually a uh revenue
expansion opportunity where they'll say
hey we're still going to get 100 in the
physical world because that's a certain
demographic of people who are buying it
but we're going to add in the younger
demographics the people who are buying
stuff virtually etc and those people
are going to come and buy the digital
avatar stuff but it's a net new growth
opportunity for these luxury providers i
just don't think i would do it and so
that's probably different than if i go
talk to a 15 year old and they're like
dude you're a loser you're a boomer uh
of course you should buy this yeah this
really feels like we're just
back in the 2000s with our bratz dolls
and our and our what was the pet one pet
rock no not that chia pet pets something
with a z no no it was like tamagotchi no
it was online and you had an avatar and
i think you could pay to like change
their clothes and stuff but like we're
reliving the 2000s guys oh i used to be
all up on that i didn't pay but i would
use the free feed ramp pogs
wait what's that
you never had pogs is that enough i was
bawling with the pogs no you had a
little case and they're like little
circle uh things i was trading uh i was
trading coins before y'all even knew
what the coins were
pogs yeah like punks no pogs
yeah that pots was a big thing at one
point uh if you were a nerd and you
walked around with the tamagotchi i
loved that oh my god i literally got in
trouble at school because i was sneaking
it in shocking i couldn't let the
dinosaur die
yeah exactly
i personally just stuck with the pogs is
pogs like tamagotchi no it's a physical
thing they were literally like little uh
cardboard circles thing almost like a
baseball card but it was like a whole
pogs thing and you have like a little
case and you would like put the little
thing in there oh yeah that makes no
sense but anyway it makes no sense
because it was smart people [ __ ]
they're just recreating what we already
had and then we moved away from that and
then now we're back yeah uh somebody
also said pokemon pokemon was perfect i
never got into that and magic the
gathering i never got into that either
but that was big as well i was just a
pogs guy i was pogs and let me go play
sports you can take your digital
clothing and your low-rise jeans back to
where they came yeah somebody said pogs
are all coins that they pretty much were
you had uh you had quarters and then you
had the altcoin which was palms i have
to look this up i literally have no idea
what this looks like people are like yo
pogs like what are pogs i'm telling you
paws let me let me find a place it was
p-o-g-s is uh is how you spell it this
is it p-o-g-a yeah so what would you do
it's like a little um thing you collect
them oh we're we all living under a rock
i have never seen these in my life yeah
well because you know you were hanging
out with them they're like stickers you
know us cool kids we were trading boxing
is it like a game
no i don't know if there's a game or not
i was just collecting
oh there is a game okay okay nobody
cares okay sorry it was just like yo
what pogs you got got it
yeah all right ready all right
so
private company
private rocket company spacex fired at
least five employees after it found out
they had drafted and circulated a letter
criticizing founder elon musk and urging
executives to make the firm's culture
more inclusive
what do you think
honestly like
yeah
i've gotten new information so i i
wanted to what's your information on
friday i was like yo you can't like
criticize the leadership and like try to
cause a ruckus and not expect to have
ramifications
except
the one data point that i learned later
which wasn't i don't think obvious to
everyone in the beginning is uh
supposedly the letter was written
directly to them it was not published
publicly it was not done to uh like
embarrass them publicly it was more of
like we're writing a letter directly to
you
you like we disagree with whatever i
still think
you should expect some ramifications uh
but that's different than like if
somebody's like hey i'm an active
employee at a company let me write an
open letter and post it on the internet
to like bring you know uh kind of
negative side effects to the company uh
that's i agree i actually think like
letters like this and it just shows that
like people care
so if i write you a letter will i get
fired
no oh see open and inclusive
by the way yes i see you guys talking
about pogs and slammers slammers was i
wasn't as much into that but pogs was
real all right learning today what's
going on with the monster hunt okay okay
so
this is i'm really excited about this
this um i don't know what angie.com is
but i think it's like a whatever
they put together a really cool
visualization of the largest residential
homes in every u.s state
and um it's very interesting the average
size of a newly constructed home in the
us has more than tripled over the last
75 years from 797 square feet in 1945 to
2491 square feet in 2020
that's crazy yeah do we have photos we
do have photos wait i don't know which
state photos we have
top five top five top five top five
before you show no
okay all right go ahead go ahead just
just do the first one do you want it do
you want to guess which i'm actually the
first ones in new york
okay let me guess the five states
okay sure new york texas
uh california
uh
florida and i'll go with uh
georgia no phones but some of them yes
um okay so the new york one you can pull
it up please
it's
110
000 square feet john paulson owns you
know who john paulson is yeah
yeah shorted the housing crisis oh yes
yes yes yeah the irony of then owning
110 000 square foot homes that's what
happens when you bet against the house
prices everywhere else in the country
number two is california yep three is
four
oh you just go back for one second hold
on hold on what this the fact they're
counting this oh yeah like this was like
a controversial one yes technically it
was purchased for 141 million but like
is it done i don't know 105 000 square
feet pretty big okay
30 car cart florida versailles
uh who owns oh david seagull yep all
right 35 car garage number four
surprising go ahead missouri
chateau oh pennsylvania i i figured that
was my guess what georgia was like it'd
be some weird place i think you made a
good point it's maybe not the most
expensive but the largest yeah how many
is a 72 000 square foot i mean 72 000
square feet liz insane and five is
washington xanadu 2.0 is that how you
say it 66 thousand square feet oh
well on the graphic it says own
xanadu 2.0 what's xanadu mean google
that real quick it's like a it's like a
thing it's just google it's just to make
sure now
xanadu it's like what is it yeah it's
like a
a person
it's a fantasy thing hold on
yeah it's like
i don't know
so do they do this
fantasy but it came from like a greek
mythology people are gonna oh my god
people again so does that mean destroy
us in the comments does that mean uh
they had a xanadu 1.0
probably yeah all right all right
friends it's been a pleasure mine these
were great topics pleasure is all mine
thank you very much
i hope you guys learned something
everything i'm getting kicked off but
truly the pleasure is
what hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time